Explain why
God is called ahad. Oh, let's see. We
may have a customer.
Guys, am I getting lead or that guy
chicken ran? You little coward.
Hold on.
Nail in the coffin. Pray for me. I got
to do cardio four times this week.
Little coward, you're out, huh, Nathan?
You little coward. Buck, buck, buck.
This is the lineup. NO MORE LITTLE
CHICKENS.
OKAY. SO, WE GO RIGHT HERE. I'M quoting
here.
Using sword or gematria or jamatria,
however you pronounce it. Numerology of
redemption based on the teachings of the
Lubavitcher
Rebbe
Menachem Schneerson.
You know what the topic is, right,
Nathan?
Yeah, what's going on? Can you hear me?
Yeah, you know what the topic is, right?
Yes, Old Testament, uh, the Trinity and
the
>> What's your background? What do you
believe? I am an Orthodox Jew. I I'm not
like a Hasidic or anything, but that's
my theology.
Baruch Hashem, brother.
So, I was going to quote Schneerson,
whom you like, about ahad.
Do you want me to quote him for you or
not? I mean, go ahead, yeah. I mean, I
agree with you. Ahad
intrinsically just means one. It's
neutral in the sense that it doesn't
prove plurality, but it also doesn't
prove that it's also single. But, it can
be used uh,
it depends on the context, though.
Exactly. So, when rabbis like Singer try
to say it revolves to Trinity, he's
exaggerating, isn't he?
Well, yeah, it's not a matter of
exaggeration. I think that it's just
being honest to the context in terms of
when it's used. So, if you're using it
in a set,
yeah, like in Genesis when Adam and Eve
are made one flesh, obviously the
context there is a compound unity.
Listen, I know you want to preach the
choir. I I know that. You're not being
honest to the context, when you ignore
the fact
that in your Pentateuch, or as you want
to call it the Torah,
you have clear evidence that you have
more than one divine entity appearing,
such as the angel of the Lord that even
the Talmud had a problem with.
You want me to show you that from the
Talmud, the problem they had with the
angel?
>> Sure, I would love to go into the angel
of the Lord. Sam, actually I did want to
address one thing cuz what actually
prompted me to want to come up with when
you brought up the word of the Lord
Mhm. in Jeremiah.
Sure. As a distinct person.
You want me to show you that from the
context?
>> Yeah, can you Yeah, can you go ahead and
show that? But also, I would since
you're using this to prove the Trinity,
I am curious in terms of how you're
deriving that out of this. There's three
persons within the Godhead. Because the
word is not the spirit, the spirit is
not the word, and the word and the
spirit are not God. I'll get there. Be
patient, brother. Take a deep breath.
So, I want you to tell me whose hand
touched Jeremiah's mouth?
Now, the word of Yahweh came to me
saying, "Before I formed you in the
innermost parts, I knew you.
Before I came out from the womb, I set
you apart. I have given you as a prophet
to the nations."
Then I said, "Alas, Lord Yahweh, behold,
I do not know how to speak, because I'm
a youth." But Yahweh said to me, "Do not
say I am a youth, because everywhere I
send you, you shall go.
And all that I command, you shall speak.
Do not be afraid of them, for I'm with
you to deliver you," declares Yahweh.
Then Yahweh set forth his hand and
touched my mouth, and Yahweh said to me,
"Behold, I put my words in your mouth."
So, who's this Yahweh that touched him
physically?
So, I I would say that the Yahweh and
then Jeremiah the Yahweh in terms of the
word is just the word of Hashem himself.
So, is the word of Hashem the one
touching him physically?
Set forth his hand and touched my mouth,
and Yahweh said to me, "Yeah, so I mean
I would put here in terms of like the
anthropomorphic hands." I don't think I
don't I don't know if I would take that
as a literal, necessarily. He touched
his mouth. I think I think the hand is
using it in a way where it's
once again, it's using anthropomorphical
type of language. Honey, is is
Jeremiah's mouth an anthropomorphism or
is it an actual mouth?
>> No, it's an actual mouth. It's the hand
that's amputated.
>> Did he feel something physically touch
his mouth?
Sure, yeah, of course. Okay, so I'm not
asking you to allegorize it and get away
with the clear teaching of the text. All
I asked you was, so we can keep it
simple,
who touched his mouth? It says Yahweh.
Who? Correct. Yahweh.
The father touched him.
>> Hashem touched him, yes. Whether it was
spirit- spiritually. Father touched him,
so the father's honor touching his
mouth? Sure, you can say that the
Hashem's presence touched his mouth,
absolutely.
>> said it was the presence, the Shekinah,
which is not identical to Hashem as you
like to use the term. Because the
Shekinah
is God's presence, which even in the
Talmud equates it with his ruach, his
spirit. Correct, yeah. It's the divine
presence, 100%. So, it's the spirit?
Sure, you can say it's the spirit,
divine presence. It's just one way or
the other, no matter however you try to
slice it, Sam, it still doesn't know
that it's a individual person.
>> you because the text is clear that
Yahweh that touched him is the word of
Yahweh, and I'm still trying to get you
to be honest to admit it because it says
the word of Yahweh is speaking.
Correct, yes. The word of Yahweh, but
it's you know, of course it's God. Davar
Hashem, Hashem's word is speaking,
correct.
>> Okay, so the word speaks.
Yeah, that's what words do. They're
they're speaking, they're speech.
>> don't speak. You speak with your words.
Right. So, if I say to you, Sam, hey
listen, the word of Sam came to me,
right? Somebody's sending your word to
me. Is is your word speaking or is it
the word that came from you that is
actually speaking? So, my word that came
to from me spoke to you, so my word came
and spoke to you, right?
How did my word come and speak to you?
Well, it depending on whatever medium
came through. So, if somebody sent me a
text message, somebody sent me a
voicemail, somebody sent me a voice note
with your word.
>> In my life, in the context, how did the
word come to
Jeremiah? Let's stop your tap dance with
your iPhones and your computers. I'm not
tap dancing. I'm giving you a good
analogy so that way you can actually
see exactly how it works, Sam.
You can talk over me and I'm going to
muzzle you. Listen to the argument.
Okay. We're not Jeremiah's not in the
21st century. He didn't have an iPhone
for Hashem's word to come and speak to
him. So, how did the word of Yahweh come
to speak to him? He sent him an iPhone?
No, he didn't give him
No, no, he sent him a prophetic 5G
SMS. So, How did he come? Whose hand
touched him physically? It's Hashem that
touched him, but I don't believe
Yeah, I don't believe it was a physical
hand that came and touched him.
And so, you don't believe Jeremiah's
physical mouth got physically touched.
No, I believe the mouth is. It's the
hand that's anthropomorphic.
But he got physically touched by it. He
felt it physically touch him. What was
physically touching him?
Physically touching meaning that there
was a presence that touched him. Okay,
brother, you don't need to cuz you're
wasting my time. You got to get Hold on,
hold on. Before you let me go, I want to
address the word though. No, you're not
going to address anything. Get out of
here because I'm going to give you one
more chance. Okay, give me one more
chance, man. Listen, I actually want to
have a good dialogue with you, Sam. I'm
not also here to like I always find with
kids who keep repeating the same
question.
>> I'm not being a kid with you, Sam. I
really do believe this is
anthropomorphic language. So, let's see.
Let's see. I'm going to give you one
more. I'm going to give you one more
chance. Sure. Also, the word of Yahweh
came to me saying, "The hands of
Zerubbabel have laid the foundation of
this house,
and his hands will finish it. Then
you'll know that Yahweh of hosts has
sent me to you."
Yahweh sent who to who?
So, let me just read this again. Also,
the word of Hashem came to me saying,
"The hands of Zerubbabel have laid the
foundation of the house, and his hands
will finish it. Then you will know that
Yahweh of hosts has sent me to you.
Sent who to who?
So the hands of Zerubbabel laid the
foundation of this house.
And the hands and his hands will finish
it. So Hashem's hands will finish it.
Sent who to who?
Then you'll know that Yahweh of hosts
has sent me to you. He's talking to the
prophet Zechariah.
Then you'll know that Yahweh sent me to
you. Sent who to who?
To Zerubbabel.
Who sent who?
>> Also for the word of Yahweh Hold on. So
also the word of Yahweh came to me
saying that the hands of Zerubbabel have
laid the foundation of this house. And
his hands will finish it. Then you'll
know that Yahweh of hosts has sent me to
you. I'm not I I need to know what the
context is. So I'm sorry. I just don't
>> is talking to Zechariah.
He's telling Zechariah when Zerubbabel
finishes laying the foundation of the
house,
then you, Zechariah, will know that
Yahweh of hosts has sent me to you. Who
did Yahweh send to Zechariah to speak to
him? The uh the Yahweh of hosts.
Bye-bye, Nathaniel. Get out of here.
Okay. Bye-bye.
Yep. Get out of here.
I tried, right?
You guys saw that, right? I tried.
So Yahweh of hosts sent Yahweh of hosts,
which we agree.
He couldn't admit that it's the word of
Yahweh speaking.
The word of Yahweh saying, "Zechariah,
when Zerubbabel lays the foundation of
the house, then you're going to know
that Yahweh sent me, the word, to speak
to you."
Okay? We tried.
I tried, right? Son of his right? Do you
blame me?
You see the tap dance they do?
1,001
tap dances, and they cannot deal with
the text. Yeah, well, you know, like an
iPhone.
Jeremiah lived in the 6th century,
buddy. He didn't have an iPhone. How did
the word come to Jeremiah, and what
physically touched him?
See, the Old destroys rabbinic Judaism.
It's a nightmare rabbinic Judaism. Shows
rabbinic Judaism is from the pit of hell
and the rabbis are tools of Satan.
They perverted the Old Testament, so
their God is not the God of the Old
Testament. You're seeing it, right? We
go with what their text says and they
can't answer.
Do you see that?
You see that, right? It's an
anthropomorphism. So, what physically
touched
Jeremiah's physical mouth? Jeremiah felt
something physically touch his mouth.
Oh, that's the hand of Hashem.
So,
who is Hashem here? The father? Oh, it's
his presence. See the See this where
they play a game with you. The presence
means the Shekinah. The Shekinah.
Shekinah.
So, that's a distinction right there.
I tried. You guys weigh me?
You guys weigh me?
That just tells you I don't waste time.
You're not going to answer questions,
well, don't waste my time. I'm not here
just to debate for the sake of debating.
Okay. Now, you saw how airtight these
arguments are, right?
You saw that?
But, also be wise. Don't waste your time
and useless quarrels and debates. If
they don't answer what's in front of
their own eyes, out of here. I'm not
here to waste time.
Okay?
Keep that in mind.
I know people like spiritual bloodbaths.
I don't. I'm going to give you a chance
to be honest with the text. Now, hit the
road, Jack. Now, let's come back to what
Rabbi Schneerson said.
You enjoying this nonetheless?
Yeah, but we're told not to quarrel with
people,
right? And avoid a divisive person.
Okay, but you guys enjoyed it so far?
All right.
Glory to the true Hashem who's the
trying Hashem father, son, and spirit.
Glory to Hashem Jesus, the Lord Jesus.
Another Israeli-born Jew who loves Jesus
Christ, worships Jesus Christ, and
worships the Trinity.
Baruch Hashem Yeshua.
Not Baruch Hashem, Baruch Hashem Yeshua.
All right.
Shalom Haverim.
Guys, don't come up here if you're not
going to answer your questions. You
understood how he got set up. I want you
to learn.
Be spiritual chess players. Oh, it's an
anthropomorphism.
But Jeremiah felt something physical
touch his mouth physically. You see
where they get stumped?
Let me show you why they get stumped.
What did Jeremiah feel physically touch
his mouth physically? A hand. He felt a
hand physically touch him. Whose hand?
Yahweh. What which person of Yahweh? The
text said it was the word of Yahweh.
You guys got it, right?
You got it correct, anyway.